التضخم عنوان اخر لازمه مستمره فبعد سنوات
من التضخم الضعيفه وحتى المستقر الا ان
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا والارتفاع
الحاد في اسعار الطاقه بدل الوضع سجل
التضخم مستويات غير مسبوقه منذ سبعينيات
والثمانينات دافعا ملايين العائلات في
الدول الناميه الى الفقر ومهددا الاسر في
الدول الفقيره بمزيد من البوس غير انه بدا
يتباطئ او بدا يتباطئ الى 10% في منطقه
اليورو في نوفمبر وسته بالمئه في الولايات
المتحده في اكتوبر ويمكن ان يتراجع التضخم
في الدول المتطوره والناشئه الكبرى من
مجموعه العشرين في 20 23
24 حسب منظمه التعاون والتنميه في الميدان
الاقتصادي الا ان الرئيس قسم التحليل
الاقتصاد الكلي في اوكسفورد لديه اخر
واو ويلي
وراء الركود منها التضخم العالي الذي يضغط
على استهلاك الاسر والدخل الحقيقي ويؤدي
الى تقليل الانفاق اضافه الى سياسات تجديد
الفائده التي شاهدناها على مدار السنه
وهذا يحتاج وقتا ليتجسد في الاقتصاد بشكل
حقيقي